uh oh
uh oh
oh no my opponent
oh their clock starts ticking okay
so they don't lose by four of it
i've never played edward bishop hands
whoa it's wrong for 500k
thanks so much
donating
50 40.
oh maybe for 505
504 000 subscribers
so i'm at 504k on youtube
well thanks so much
uh rosen fan club member
i'm paying some large jews there
i really appreciate the support
we have a savard
i don't think we've had the stafford
this stream yet
it's not a true stream without a
stafford and we have the magical line
opponent seems kind of prepared
yeah this is cold-pressed watermelon
juice
the problem is it might make my lips
turn red
they're more red than they already are
i play the swiss tournament in
switzerland i have not
i was in switzerland for one day i flew
into basel
but didn't stay very long
okay opponent taking their sweet sweet
time
even sweeter than my juice
oh i guess i did have a stafford as
as white opponents tried to stafford me
but
i've been busy playing the halloween
oh f4 is interesting
f4
wait a minute
did i just play h4
five
i'm not sure if i ever looked into f4
i'm just continuing with the themes and
oh no my knight and my bishop
this is really risky though given that
uh
i'm not super booked up
but the brief calculation this takes
takes
and it takes i play g2 rook g1 queen h4
and
there's a lot of camera play
i think you ready play ready player one
the five months
i mean there's this move
we should be having a good time
the nice thing about the swiss
tournament 2 is that when i finish my
game
i can commentate other games
amazon
oh thank you atomic clock
okay i'm liking the looks of this
i should consider this move or even this
move but
this looks fun because i hit the bishop
i super pin i have the battery pane
against the rook the pawn
i'm threatening g2
to promote
and win stuff
thank you radio math
yeah so the things amazon reference is
if you have amazon prime
you can subscribe for free
just like what atomic clock and radio
math did radio math something for the
first time with prime
um yeah g2 looks really nice
this might be even nicer actually
wait let's calculate takes
let's assume queen takes
and then i i push
takes yeah let's take
good evening
incognito also something with prime
yeah so now that this move
targets the king and hits a rook
and if takes i i in between move
so i could potentially have two queens
like if this i take and
yeah i'll have multiple queens
brain spew also something with prime
okay
i feel so powerful now
oh and frank the tank
also priming
oh can i castle with meat
oh
oh it doesn't work though
[Music]
i need the queen to go away
wait how do i how do i orchestrate this
oh there's also that move
edward bishop hands can only count to
two or four in binary
but if edward bishop hands underpromotes
to so many more bishops
then edward bishop hands can promote or
can can count to more probably
diamondsman one
uh
i don't think i did
oh i did queen e4 was made
okay
i did it the hard way
okay thank you i've heard bishop hands
yeah so stockfish really likes this for
white but
it's the magical thing about this line
is it's easy to kind of go wrong
wow plus seven
so takes takes
i mean this just looks really complex
though queen h4
yeah i'd probably play this again
e5 all it takes is one mistake
yeah i was excited about this i was
gonna play rook h5
say oh no my rook
and then castle queenside with mate
that could have been fun
anyway uh back to tournament
27 games ongoing so that's round one of
12.
oh ipsy says chat would like to see you
playing one cloud
39 voted for that second was halloween
okay i'll play a bong cloud my next game
just for the
fans feel really dirty doing it
oh pepe playing
oh okay i'm gonna feel really bad doing
this but
i mean chad voted for a bomb cloud so
i'm delivering
okay we're gonna unbond cloud
and now maybe play a hippo
i'll play hippo because why not
hey it's gary what's up gary
sorry i was here earlier
gary if you want to do kung fu chess
much later like after this tournament
i still want to do some kung fu chassis
stream
now you know what it is
basically deja vu
infinite youtube content
haven't heard the gary bits in a while
oh did you just see this opening in the
video
oh that would be funny
okay
so i can't legally castle because my
king has already moved twice
however i can
get some playable
position hope the people in chat are not
also like playing a game
like people playing a game should be
focused on their game rather than
chatting
but maybe there's some people just
watching
eric toggy where is danny
oh probably hanging out with waldo
be my guess
uh
nf3
i want to castle the counseling's not
legal
[Music]
i'll play another three
maybe reroute the bishop
yes i'm aware of the various bomb clubs
that hikaru has played and that carlson
played
at imrozen just lurking now trying to
stay awake you can always nap and return
later for the end
the grand finale
i'm trying to stay awake too
but i'm not really lurking i'm just
what's the opposite of lurking
non-lurking
it's actually a reasonable move
might as well take with pawn hey it's
nemo what's up nemo
i mentioned nemo's name at some point
recently
i was referring to the stafford lesson
that we had shout out to nemo
and thank you oolong kalufin gifting to
nemo
aka nebsco
for those just joining
i'm doing a 12 hour stream we are in
hour six
over six and a half hours in
also for those just joining i
was peer pressured into playing a bomb
cloud
which i'm still
feeling a bit dirty about
yeah the position's actually not really
good
let's take and
try and survive maybe h4 coming
i'm also keeping track of
people who are rating so thank you to
aka numsko
play bishop bishop h3
i think what i want to do is
on cloud again
i did it once and now i kind of want to
do it again
really
that move is kind of scary but i don't
think it works because i have this
i think the bishop and winning a bishop
if takes i take with king
this looks reasonable
also is emote only mode time
unless you're a vip
or mod
or cheer bits i guess
okay
oh
so black tried to pin me
but now got discover forked
oh i still can't castle
uh and if i play those there's f3
gas queen
d2 i have to float like a butterfly
and sting like a stingray
who said that
muhammad ali
okay he wants to be here
plenty of time too
he wants to be here rick wants to be
here
etc etc
or bruce lee
oh taki's been
trying to get vip for one year now
i can make taki vip
okay
oh no
ah
[Music]
i unmodded tagi
to make toggy vip
but now i just realized i don't have any
more vip slots
i have to unvip
someone
what do you mean when you say that a
position is sharp
oh sharp uh like a knife
or a spike
oh no
my target
okay target is a vip now
the time has come
now itagi came back channel points and
predictions
oh okay let's play this move
oh should i make gary a mod gary do you
want to be a mod
the thing with vips and mods is i can
make
unlimited people mods but there's only
there's a limit to the number of vips
uh let's play this move
thank you leo no
stopping with prime for four months
olgari doesn't want the responsibility
fair enough
wait can you be vip and mod
oh also thanks for the game oval
stingray
yeah that was a weird game
we got a little bit distracted towards
the end there
anyway back to tournament let's watch a
game
um
fancy looking position
wow
oh no locks king
so now back still of a pawn this is
interesting
anything can happen
game could take a while
yeah all three results were possible
that's very true
anything can happen either cycle flag
either side could blunder a queen or
getting mated
or a pawn
it's entertaining though
wow
[Music]
oh no it's queen
my queen g2 was draw
wait
oh queen g2 yeah it would force a draw
that's true
but better to win the queen
oh fancy fancy
the game
there was force mate uh
oh and zelda queen e2 there's h5
king g5 and queen g3 mate was uh
would have been a nice one
good fight though
okay back to tournament next round
starts in the second
okay no more blonde cloud
playing
something something
uh
play e5
yeah no stafford
have a two nights i guess
jerome why could jeromey if white wants
would you what is jerome
oh jerome is after bishop c5
never mind
debating what to play here
i think i'll play b5 looks like a cool
line
i think they call this the olvis strat
over distract i forget the name of this
it has a name that starts with a u a u l
v something something
where like apparently the best move is
bishop f1 after b5
oh i could have played the track sir but
this is equally
almost as equally as cool
uh let's play this
overstat yeah
oh did pepe discuss it on stream
someone commented that they wanted to
see
a video on this one
uh
i think the comment was on my oh
sullivan video
yeah so hitting the knight
if rookie won probably bishop e7
right here i have a retreating square
um
debating between this and this
like this is slightly
actually let's play this
depending upon preventing f3
if king h1 i can play knight g4
yay in blue jaches love from toronto d
hey welcome
blue jay
okay so i'm pretty much out of
watermelon juice
i have some
tea left almost out of tea too
at least i'm staying hydrated
okay so now yeah now i think it makes
sense for the bishop to come here
yeah am i more vulnerable without my
watermelon juice
okay attacking the rook
i feel like the watermelon juice just
made me more powerful though
okay i was also threatening mate
so
let's take a look
yeah these pieces are kind of stuck
so the bishops pinned to the queen the
queen's tied down to defending the
bishop
knight is dominated by my pawns
i guess the king could move
i feel bad for kind of laughing
the white almost has no moves
let's just improve
improve my thing
okay i'll start eating some pawns
there is a mexican defense
also known as the night's tango
maximum defenses d4 c4 knight f6 knight
c6
okay pawns are being consumed
oh 250 players in the tournament yeah
it's still not too late to join
they're still
what we're in round three
so probably three more rounds to join
oh
well that force is a queen trade i'm
gonna move back
and recapture at the bishop
just had a cool idea of on passantmate
again it's hard to make happen but with
a pawn on the fifth rank like this
if i ever can induce f4
i mean there's on passant like this
i'm not going to un-poisson because i
want to save the other ambassador for
when it's even more powerful
okay let's get some more pawns rolling
get the rook involved
i'm realizing my knight wants to be here
my knight also doesn't appreciate being
pinned
okay let's play this move
so there was a prediction earlier
uh
of whether or not i'll win this
tournament
so i am motivated to prove all the
doubters wrong
so i think it was more
more people predicted i wouldn't win
i'm trying to start strongly
okay
and go after the rook
oh if you're playing on mobile
i don't recommend using the leachate app
it's my four-month sub anniversary
oh thank you geek guam happy four months
yeah if you're playing on mobile uh
leachates works really well in mobile
browser
and the app is a bit more limited when
it comes to features
the king of one mission b5 is mate
otherwise okay rook g3 or rook f3
g3 will fall
yeah they have the leachate's app before
the chess version 2 existed but version
2 made it so that
uh lichas was like completely responsive
for mobile
as far as i know
okay white has two knights
i have two bishops
and so many pawns
yeah sadly there's not going to be any
on passant mates
white doesn't have any more pawns left
like an umbassant
okay thanks for the game murdo insane
uh bishops open oh yeah this was uh
overstand
all the stat variation
yeah bathroom bishop f1
what happened here
i guess was pretty pleasant
that's still equal
okay back to tournament
okay
so the way a swiss tournament works is
normally you'll play people who have the
same score so the more games i keep
winning
the stronger my opponents will get
because
i'm also playing people who want all
their games
oh let's watch a game
this looks interesting
tremor bond against 91
black has two pawns and a bishop
white's making a queen
yeah we'll see what happens
actually similar to the previous game
that we saw
i feel like all three results were
possible here
[Music]
this is kind of crazy
i don't want to say anything until the
game finishes
we'll just watch and
be an r
eq trokar xx
it's a pretty intense position
like trying to figure out how to how to
win
wow e2 black could have repeated
ah it's still made ah it's so funny
hey it's stalemate
is it winning like i was actually
curious
next game might be starting yeah next
round starts very soon um
[Music]
instead of
because normally like if the king is
anywhere else like even here
it would be made in two after this and
this
uh
maybe this this this yeah this is
winning
and then this
queen d4 pinning the pawn here and then
mate
good game okay
oh playing ruby
this is probably ruby lol from twitch
chat
i'll play london
got the game open in two tabs
ooh dutch
like ruby lol before
i'll play knight c3
mix it up a little bit
no london
yeah it should still be possible to join
there are
267 players playing
yeah so this is going to be you know
what we call this variation
but um
it's one of the lines in the dutch bit
more solid
i am close to my peak rating actually i
don't think i've ever hit
2700 blitz
but uh
i think i've hit like 26 90 something
not too far off
oh maybe i'll play this move
although black wants to castle
maybe i'll play a3 first
preventing any shenanigans
thank you sir squirtle for a while but
now i'm back for the stream hey welcome
back
yeah we'll have
we'll have about five more hours of
streaming
we're just past the seven hour mark
i'm not sure what i'll do towards the
end of the stream because i'm going to
be tired
i might like stoop lower i might do some
variants or bullet shots something to
keep me awake
uh takes takes queen h5
looks fun
oh do i look super tired i'm just trying
to stay calm
hopefully i'm i'm still
emitting some type of energy
i have to remember to stretch too
so this is round four of the of the
tournament
all rounds total
oh
on is kind of hanging
play this
and i have three coming
also h7 is hanging so
i really want to be up a pawn
that's possible
at some point i could play music
um
but that probably comes later
would you ever create a new account and
do a speedrun yes
yeah i want to do that i don't think
it's so feasible on leeches
but
i think it's pretty easy to do that on
chess.com i just need to message support
okay
here goes the pawn
threatening this pawn too
if casting queen side i have knight b5
looks nice
what's the weirdest opening you know
i played the squirrel earlier
the squirrel was pretty weird
oh don't worry i'm not starving myself
i had a nice you can bar
uh gave me some energy
but there's still some bar left
oh there's a very small piece of bar
my bar piece
okay
um yeah box under pressure here
i think either this or that
no i have this move
rook d8
maybe i'll delay bond cloud
blackwell's threatening bishop b4
yeah rook c7
someday
f4 is a fine move
not entirely sure how to handle this
actually
i could go after this bishop
wait what what am i doing
it's about to just blonder at night
oh that's not a good sign
oh that's a really bad sign
[Music]
i saw the bishop i just didn't see the
rook
okay let's play rook g1
the more trades we do and the less
blunders i can make
oh no
that's not a good sign of things to come
i don't know how i could like make this
move
put the knight right next to the rook
at least we're trading some stuff
and then long term i want to play knight
g5
oh
oh what's the longest classical otb game
i've played in terms of hours
um
[Music]
so there's a game
i played in indonesia
there's a chile chop open
and this was
2019 i think it was january 2019
and it was a nine-round tournament
and it was a friday
i play the game
oh thank you sunshine
something something something gaming
i was just telling a story
oh yeah the longest tournament game i
played um
it was like a very long time control
and
the game started
and about four hours in
the game got adjourned
because on friday like
they had like prayer or something
um
like a prayer day or session
so i had to seal my move
and then
the game was adjourned for like hour and
a
half
and my opponent went to pray
and after i sealed my move i had to like
i had to still like calculate the
position but i couldn't look at the
board so i just had to calculate
blindfolded for
over an hour
and then the game lasted like another
two hours after that
and then i eventually won the game and
then had another game to play
that same day it was such a long day
so
the game itself if you include the
adjournment it was well over six hours
and my second game of the day i
like four hours
it was pretty brutal
so
if i compare today's streaming day to
that day
uh
this is kind of just a piece of cake
or a pizza cake
okay threatening this
black's way below this game up a pawn
but uh i'm probably about to win on time
i'm trying to induce this move so i can
fork
oh but the thing's defended
oh but this is not defended
let's start eating ponds
okay
i'm glad to
make it through this game given that i
almost played knight g5
i was i was really close to playing
knight g5
okay back to the tournament thank you
ruby
oh how do you stay patient in really
long games
i mean when you play like years and
years of like classical tournament chess
you kind of learn how to
just kind of deal with the
the long ones
um
and usually in the midst of a game
there's always something to think about
so
keeping patience is not really an issue
sometimes it's just a matter of like
not getting too lost in thought and then
getting low on time
oh thank you cube oh yes
my shirt hey
cube i wonder if you're a pawn cube or a
different type of cube
thanks for ordering merch
uh 289 players this might be the last
round to late join i'm not sure
there might be one round after this
thank you jay mauricion
gifting to eat puke
oh i'm playing godly apple
hey we played twice before
uh
let's unleash my new my new pet opening
b5
yeah if you want to join the tournament
use the join command
click the link
you mercelluv spy and omniarmnon
okay
what to do i could take this
or i could not take it i could play g5
let's play nah
g5 just hangs upon
i'll play e6 let's be normal
maybe at 906
being somewhat normal here
gl
oh thank you
for the good luck wishes
okay got my battery
my bishops
oh people sharing jokes in the chat
what's a frog's favorite animal
a rabbit
oh because ribbit uh
some of these jokes i've heard before
what's the best thing about switzerland
i don't know
but the flag is a big plus
very clever
okay i should focus here
thank you zio
[Music]
a new sub
[Music]
why not take on f2 if i took on f2
there's rook f2 um
and then king f2 if i take with
queen so
wait did i i didn't have that earlier no
or did i
no i didn't
i don't think i did
i've been hallucinating a little bit so
far this tournament but
not overly hallucinating
um can just calmly develop
there's d5 as well there's rook c8
maybe rook c8
pressure the file
oh would knight g4 work actually it was
interesting
queenie one
i think
maybe i would get the rook and pawn for
two minor pieces but generally that's a
better trade for whites
so it's not usually a
thing i'd like to go for
we can analyze after if there's time
okay this move actually looks
is it blocks in my bishop
why wants to play this
maybe 94
and 94.
cause
oh thank you i've been 75.
also a big thank you to everyone and
we've passed we're at 233 subs for this
stream
it's uh
it's a nice number
unfortunately i didn't know i didn't
keep track of who was a the 200th sub of
the stream
i appreciate everyone's support
okay also appreciate this position this
is bishop's completely locked in
my knight wants to come to c4 someday
and probably the setup involves like 97
if i should trade
i might as well
57
i was going to say bishop f6
probably queen b7
[Music]
and bishop e3 is probably coming
there's two ways to get to c4
thank you nroc pop 49
oh backwards popcorn ah i'm usually
sharp enough to recognize that before i
say the name
uh backwards
popcorn it's been six months
okay i'm pretty sure i'm sharp enough to
see tactics so
ah but there's uh there's this move
i could just make a looft
also play this move
another idea
okay let me start with this
so i'm inviting rookie five also
inviting this move
hey pepe
in rosa for 13 months
i appreciate that
yeah we gotta activate the arrows
the one thing that can keep me awake
it's tactics
okay was what i was waiting for
i didn't play e5 because there was
knight f3
oh there's this move
wow godly apple
what's happening here actually
there's this move but then this move
it actually gets really complicated
if i take
i mean taking looks very natural but
it might be better just to take here it
takes takes
if hero takes takes rook here i have
this
yeah it's probably better
i really hope i'm not missing anything
here
i'm prone to missing things thank you
pepe gifting to a
sv
1681
i'm aware of yeah um
the back rank is defended by the knight
so in the event of takes takes
i know
inventive takes takes
rook 8 i have knight takes 8.
apologies if my arrows are off
yeah so that's why i was calculating
rook a6 which would attack the knight if
my knight moves it might be rotate
oh there is a funny line though
to make a looft first
i'm gonna make a looft and say oh no my
knight
it's kind of funny
it's not necessary but
the point is if rook takes knight
i would check here here
or even takes first and i'll have bishop
d4
king f1 i'll check and eventually the
king will land here and they'll win the
rook oral queen
yeah and there's no check
i've made
seems a little bit close
okay good game godly apple
uh real quick i'll analyze there's a
question about this bishop f2 knight g4
like maybe here
yeah but in general
if i'm just winning the rook
the two miners are better than rook and
pawn
yeah so far like when i played b5
against d4 no one's going into the
oh sullivan
even though it's the most likely move
order
i guess a lot of people like to stick
with like london or catalan type things
oh st louis chess club oh there's a lot
of people streaming this
including stl chess club oh that's so
awesome
to st louis chess club
hey
oh it's harrison
this is uh arcg3 streaming on the saint
louis just club channel
i appreciate the the streamers streaming
blue jay chess
mr kushage
yeah let's give some shout outs
when in dao play an ad should i play an
ad
oh you have to do things to get rewards
it ends in a few
you have to vote
and then get me like if you vote you you
give me bits
so how many bits can i
what is this let's let's go with uh the
axe cause
it rhymes with porkchop
oh no there's eight seconds left
everyone quick quick five seconds
okay 50 plus votes
so i guess we just i just got 290 bits
okay that was fun
what's my favorite chess variant
kung fu chess
i'll do some kung fu chest later
wait did i play this appointment before
i feel like i shouldn't fool around
oh this opponent beat me earlier excited
for your 120 hour stream when you reach
5 mil subs
oh dear no that's not how oh wait is
that how it works that might be how it
works
yeah when i reach 5 million subscribers
on youtube i'll do a subathon
you can clip this and save it for the
future
hey it's irene what's up irene
just for irene we're gonna play a london
auntie london
irene is maybe just waking up
yeah i'm going to play this f6 line it's
kind of a new trendy ish line
not too many people are exposed to yet
and g5
and yeah the idea is to play in some
like job london style
e6 h5
etc etc
maybe some bishop d6
oh feingold fuming after f6
yeah normally it's f6 is terrible
especially like early in the opening
like this
but it's justified
it's also computer approved too
okay so pawns being attacked
i'm wondering if i can
just sack it
like play bishop d6
queen b7 knight here but then bishop b5
if i play queen b6 first takes takes
bishop c7
so let's be careful
a queen b3 is surprisingly annoying
i have queen c8
the queen's a bit misplaced there
some idea of like playing this and then
rook h7 but it's moved too slow
okay uh i think i'll play queen c8
it looks so wrong though maybe queen d7
actually
i don't know why i rejected queen g7
immediately
at queen d7 defend the pawn still
supporting d6
yeah for those just joining i've been
live for over seven half hours
trying to still play decent chess
yeah this is one of the more exotic ways
to play against london
[Music]
i want to trap a bishop okay now i want
to attack the knights
yeah going for just some setup
knight g7
maybe eventually e5
and this is beginning to feel more like
blitz we both upped up the tempo
wondering knight a5 a6
some idea
there's also this idea
[Music]
okay there's kind of a funny line takes
takes takes
and then oh no white's queen
wow
i want to play this but then f4
i'll play b5 preventing c4
okay get the king out the way of any
danger
i'm liking the position
[Music]
and white's a bit stuck
my pieces are very restricted
and both knights are just restricted by
my my pawns
wow
[Music]
play this
move
as it prevents f4 which i think was
white's only like active move
now the bishops completely suck queen
side down to the knight
knight only swear for the knight to move
is h1
sorry for laughing
both rooks don't have any legal moves
ah this knight could move i guess
well maybe uh listen this
ah but then this move is pawnings
[Music]
i should start with
probably start with bishop seven
now it's gonna resist
another sub bites the dust
hey
the 241st sub thank you mathletics
something
i don't know what to do here
which is a little bit concerning given
it splits i should move
i'll play this move go for e4
this game space
ideal to play
e4 maybe eventually f5
the dream would be to get all the pawns
rolling
my queen should probably go back
that was my second cup of tea it's gone
now
i have not done the simul yet
maybe i'll do a symbol at some point
[Music]
though it takes
to do this
and there's this idea
maybe this move
that way the bishop's a bit more active
now here i i can always take and
not lose material
hey the sub count has passed carlson's
rating let's go
thanks everyone
i think right all seems like 28.50
that's a difficult position for both of
us it's hard to find some plans
can't believe you're still streaming
is the tea keeping you awake
uh
actually the tea i was just drinking so
this throat comfort
it's
uh it's herbal it's not caffeinated so
[Music]
probably not i mean it's keeping me
hydrated it's a funny night
let's play
i have f3
nah
to keep my pawns intact
i mean if g3 f3 would be hilarious
okay i'm liking the position also f3 g3
would be pretty funny
this knight is gonna be stuck for a long
time
i might end up winning on time this game
okay let's take
back the pawn
okay i can be patient because white's
basically down a piece
wants to double up
on the bubble up
play this and then this
i'm gonna win on time i think
or not might's been playing quickly
enough
there you go that's what i was waiting
for
i might rerouting
let's over defend
defend everything i'm ready to take the
pawn
i take here
probably not called for
like this
i'm finding to take and take
oh
[Music]
okay there's rook
i don't know what's happening actually
it should be winning
oh it's a funny position this knight is
so sad still
which still makes me happy
okay so i'm threatening made in one
uh let's prevent
wait how do i do this
prevent rook h5
okay
there we go
okay good game that's a fun one
it's a fun london opening
i kind of felt bad for the horsey
you gatsby
something with prime for the first time
[Music]
okay back to tournament
getting merch
there once was a man named rose and he
made opponents feel frozen before it was
seen he said oh no my queen and the
checkmating line was chosen oh that's a
great great limerick
i appreciate that thank you sophie
okay next game i'll be playing
pre-launch
[Music]
only other player to have won all the
games so far
i'll play a london
yeah so this is uh i think a pretty
standard
london type of position
the queen on b6 is a bit misplaced
although black is trying to justify it
uh let's start with ricky one
i have knight c4 i think just queen e2
um
should be five might be coming
0.95 first
then here and then here
i have this move
trying to maximize pressure
now queen f3
trade
there's queen c2
there's rookie three
maybe i'll play rookie three
i'm just trying to build up the the
classic london
attack okay taking looks really
appetizing
takes takes check
let's try it it might objectively be bad
but
it looks tricky for black to defend
so knight g8 defends upon
otherwise i'm just winning the pawn
now i was thinking rook g8 is uh
it looks winning
because i'm typing made in the end
if f5 i check here mate or if you're
it's mate
all right
so i'm down a whole
rook
but most of these pieces are not
defending the king
and uh yeah there's multiple main
threats there's this threat and this
threat
f5 gets mated in two
[Music]
oh it might be too late now to join the
swiss
yeah because we're after the halfway
point
that's one of the drawbacks with swiss
is you have to
join for the first half
anyway uh thanks for the game
brian
my biggest rival this tournament
i'm curious i think bishop h6 was
objectively fine
yeah
yeah that was a feel-good london game
have you ever seen the painting the
unexpected surprise by paul charles
choccani morrow
oh i've not
i've not
um i'm not so into like historical art
so there could be like even famous
paintings i'm not aware of
ah
okay i found the painting oh it's good
painting
yeah that does look like uh i mean that
looks like a an expected surprise
based on
[Music]
what you would expect to happen you put
your hand towards the goose gooses and
mouth
oh it looks painful
nice painting though
do i use an anonymous account
i do have an account where like it's a
secret account but i don't really use it
that often
[Music]
there's usually not too many reasons to
oh oh i'm playing camel
hey the clutcher of camels okay
we played in vegas otb
a few months ago
um i think i'm gonna leave on the
pentatonic
it's soothing
oh sip tea i'm out of tea
i have no more tea
and no more watermelon juice
but i have water
ogt
[Music]
okay going for this line bishop five
yeah water is the purest form of tea
[Music]
okay
so i'm getting uh actually a classic
london trap
after bc6 all be trapping the rook
oh should i change the music i could
change it go back to normal
if people want to listen
to music you can open a new tab
but later i might put on hall of the
mountain king
it could be nice
actually let's castle
[Music]
i'll let the rook suffer
maybe c3
okay now i'll take
okay so
i'm off the exchange
i haven't really used too much time
it still takes work to convert this for
the position
[Music]
those files are closed
this bishop's annoying
ideally i would like to trade
maybe some bishop g5 move eventually
oh yeah i see the comment from leroy
named lauren me
knight d2 before
i usually play it before c3
play a b4 here
so if takes i can strengthen the
position
[Music]
or even take with queen offer queen
trade
yeah with that i'll still have to keep
c3 defended
okay giving the bishop retreating room
ooh g5
so g4 might be coming
um
yeah probably better to keep the bishop
on the long diagonal
a longer diagonal
yeah it's going to take work to convert
this
the thing is when you have a rook for
minor piece
the rook is
only useful when there's open files
this is my only half open file which is
kind of closed
which makes me kind of sad
i have this move
yeah eight hours and nine minutes
so less than four hours to go
trying to finish strong
yeah this makes me happy now
because now
now i'm up a rook
for
a couple pawns
um
i still have to stay focused and awake
which might be difficult
oh my day's been good most of my day has
been streaming been live for over eight
hours
uh there's this move
f6
i don't think that works so let's play
this first
oh do i stream on youtube also
no
i would like to but uh
like the twitch partner agreement
someday i'll try and get out of my
twitch contract or negotiate the twitch
contract
so i could stream on youtube
but there's some exclusivity clause that
some larger channels are able to get out
of
but it is kind of difficult
what to do
let me go play this and maneuver the
knight to d3
thank you superman
i was able to get the 10 move oh no my
queen checkmate in the car oh can the
other day love your call
you are constantly churning out oh thank
you
oh that's very nice here
people can get the
the traps i show
will this go on youtube
if this moment makes it to youtube
let me know in the comments
this might end up on like a
i'm thinking about launching a vods
channel
or i just post full vods
and in that case
i'd probably put this whole thing on
youtube
it would be nice just time stamp it
appropriately
yeah if you've made it this far feel
free to go back and share timestamps in
the comments
that would be nice
also what's happening here
i think i'm easily winning
those pawns hanging
oh this could be a lot trickier than
expected
uh
before
it's e5 we trade
i'm not entirely sure what to do
95
doesn't seem to work
i guess i can play 91 back
which is not the first move that came to
mind but now the point is if takes i win
the pawn
and if queen takes i also win the pawn
so i guess this whole idea didn't really
do much for me
thank you ernst jacob
oh there's question about exclusivity
yeah multi-streaming but also just
separate streaming is prevented
unfortunately
at least for most like partners and
affiliates on twitch
okay let's go after
going after the queen eventually i want
to win the pawn
man this is scary
see this move
okay i'm gonna have to focus
catch up with chad after this game
[Music]
and bishop b4 is coming
realizing there's this idea which
i have to be very careful about
the bishop before i have knight takes
okay we're making things crazy
because why not
so with rook h3 i mean it just got so
insane
i'm looking at uh knight takes bishop
takes queen e2 hitting this and this
oh that's a move
oh that's a really good move too
oh no
i have this move though
what's going on
i'm meeting
i might be meeting
when h5 is mate
or is it
it is
wow okay
oh that was an unexpected finish
i feel like
uh black almost won that
queen that for save me
a
[Music]
game camel clutcher was almost clutch
wow engine says like it's confusing
still
green c3
oh that was maiden nine queen c7
king h6
ah knight f7
so force mate like
this that's crazy
that's a funny force mate f3 mate
show this to ben feingold
okay
back to tournament
okay next round starts in the second
thank you luke paulo
okay playing jules
trying to keep my clean score
i was ready for a stafford
a king's gambit is also fun though
yeah unfortunately it's a bit too late
to join the tournament
but again not too late to watch
thank you tosser
the prime sub
i've had
a cl smith asking how many sullivans
today
um
i think i've only had one
but the one that i had was really
beautiful
f5 is objectively dubious but
most people don't know how to meet it
yeah that's the best move though
so now black's objectively worse
most people play knight c3 and then
after castling black has a lot of comp
oh time on of question
yeah i know the line that you're
referring to usually black is better in
that line
[Music]
um i think i can take this
usually white wants a queenside castle
in this line but
then
a2 falls
hey hey becker congratulations on 500
000 youtube subs
appreciate that subbing for 10 months
okay pleasant time advantage
it's an opening i haven't looked at in a
while but uh my last move of prep was f5
and now
yeah white's a bit
jumbled
and this was a counter gambit but i just
went back upon
queen here i might play bishop here
oh
now white's gamuting again
well i might as well take
i mean there's queen c4
wow
oh did i blunder i may have blundered
no i can take back
as long as i don't play queen a1
because after knight b1 i can't take is
this
or could i have 96 in that line
there's also a cree oh there's a funny
line
wait okay
so
queen a1
when a1 knight b1 knight c5 queen c4
bishop e6 queen c5
bishop a2
oh but then knight ft2
that's funny but
white is mainly the one laughing there
okay so i'll play this
jaybird welcome back
tier 2 for 29 or 25 months
thanks for being here
i'm feeling a little bit tired
hopefully i don't begin to begin
slurring my words too much
or mispronouncing numbers
okay this move looks terrifying
because white's writing this and this
i mean i have 96
i might just move here and here
no i can't do that
congrats on the 500k
thinking about vacationing to saint
louis next spring
would you be willing to play tennis with
me i'm not very good let me know if i'm
in town then probably
almost certainly
but sometimes i travel and it depends if
i'm in town or not
but that'd be cool thanks vegas subbie
yeah keep me posted though
i'm in trouble here
uh like i'm probably just losing a piece
i'm thinking like just bishop e6 lose a
knight
trying to comp
i guess i could try
the problem is still bishop's e4 and
that's losing
also i have this and this
probably doesn't work
another idea
is knight here bishop here here here and
then here
x takes king here knight g5
all these lines just look bad
what to do
i'm in trouble
[Music]
i'm taking time because i don't know
what to do
i think i just play this and try and
survive
oh i could still go for uh this line
actually
i don't think it's good
but maybe it's still tricky so takes
here here here here
it's worth a try
um
ah but there's bishop c4
that's no good
okay i'll play
this move and e3 is coming
man
okay queen a4 i guess
15 seconds
uh
and i'm down a piece
i'll try and make
try and work with what i have
some 96 plan
bullet rating
[Music]
it's a fair move
play this
i've connected my rooks
i allowed yeah allowed that discovery
oh no my position
okay
let's still try and fight
still some hope
very small ounce of hope
white's played a good game though
takes takes
i promise i'm down a rook
good move
i'm still down the rook
i'm trying to be resilient
oh that's a good move
oh opponent takes the queen rather than
mating me
oh no my position
good game though
yeah
time was the least of my worries in that
position
okay so won't be a perfect score this
tournament
oh jewels uh is now tied
ryan's also up there
wow
so this could be close
still hope to to win the tournament
yeah so
it's actually a tricky line most people
play knight t3
i think bishop e3 is like the only move
apparently knight g5 but
bishop e3 is best
knight d2
i guess knight d2 is still playable
wow
i thought castling was a mistake but i
guess
it just loses
yeah like what to do
i didn't have any hope i took on a2
which is already just losing
okay next round starts in five seconds
oh is there a stalemate oh i missed it
okay playing master of disaster
let's try and not get adopted
okay there's about four times
it'd be interesting to see how many
stalemates have emerged from this
tournament
that would be a good handful
[Music]
maybe more than like a normal tournament
i'll play knight t2
idea queen b3 coming
yeah so here there's no queen b6 because
the bishop would hang
if takes
i'd probably take back
oh we might get something
something resembling the the usual
structure
yeah to join the tournament you had to
join in the first half
it's one of the downsides of a swiss
versus arena
okay trying to play solidly here
oh why more stalemates i feel like my
viewers are probably more
keen to stalematrics than the average
person
[Music]
i haven't done blindfold yet
but i have my blindfold patiently
waiting
maybe it's becoming slightly more
impatient
as time goes on
[Music]
oh why is it called swiss arena
so swiss is actually
a type of chess pairing
or type of like format
it's like the main format that's used in
most us tournaments
called the swiss system you can look it
up on wikipedia
um i think i'll take with queen actually
bishop d5 might be coming
and there's bishop a2 b3
hey jaybird played his first
over-the-board tournament last week
nice yeah i know a lot more people are
playing their first otb tournaments
um
or have them like coming up
i hope uh hope you enjoyed it now it's a
different experience compared to playing
online
i think knight 95 gamut's a pawn
but it just gives a really nice square
for the
the knight
very nice control over e5
and bishop takes i got the g file
there's a line bishop g2
rook g1 bishop e4 bishop d3
and then let's say trade trade
i think there's some compensation for
white
i mean the bishop could move back to d5
oh i didn't see that move i have to play
king d1
but thankfully i don't have a vlog with
my queen
could have been bad
[Music]
okay life goes on that's kind of a
wake-up call though
it's nice getting woken up
even by an unexpected surprise
queen is doing two jobs
oh there's a funny move bishop h4
it works though
it might not actually work
but it might work
okay let's calculate bishop h4
green h4 queen here king here
knight here rook takes
i can't check his rook f8 i could take
back threatening mate
and then there's queen e7
[Music]
not super clear
i mean maybe what i can do is play this
first
look there there
27
that seems really close to working
but no cigar
wait a minute i still have my
lightsweight bishop in that line right
right so bishop h4 takes
uh takes king here
knight f7 takes takes
oh but i'm missing
missing too much
i might just play bishop f4
idea of this move
or i could play this and just take the
bishop
too many choices in life
i have another idea too
okay i'm gonna play my other idea play
a3
uh and then bishop d6 bishop h4
just it's just a matter of combining the
ideas correctly
so a3 brings the bishop back and then
this would divert the queen away from
defending the pawn
i mean i didn't calculate this fully i
mean there's queen e8
there's also this move
ooh
another idea
to play bishop h5
oh no bishop h5 queen takes with check
oh that doesn't work either
maybe i'll play f4
f4 looks reasonable
or even this first
but then still queen h5
that's gonna be tricky
i do have a time advantage
wow
[Music]
okay so i kind of want to take
let's assume c pawn takes takes takes
should still be some compensation
not sure what black was thinking about
there
okay probably rook c7 now
maybe black was just realizing the
danger
or not realizing the danger
okay
that worked out nicely
okay managed to recover
this complicated position i don't know i
mean it felt like i had a lot of
resources
stockfish find anything cleaner
likes bishop c4
nothing completely winning
with bishop c4 bishop d5
uh just play like gradually
wow
[Music]
okay in the lead
oh two more two more rounds two more
rounds
hey cry baby cry baby carly thanks for
the raid
okay
uh
[Music]
this is a 12 hour stream we've been
rated a bunch of times
another name to add to the list
if i can spell correctly
welcome to everyone just joining i'm
doing a viewer swiss tournament
there are two rounds left
it is a little bit too late to join but
not too late to watch
and
[Music]
yeah two more
shout outs to crybaby carly
i'll play this a6 line
also i'll turn off follower only moon
just for a moment
okay we'll try and play aggressively
this game
especially after e3 the bishop is a bit
more blocked in
you're already feeling pretty good
don't mind the trade now have the bishop
here
stafford what is there to say
take the pawn and then the knight and
eric will delight in what he plays
[Music]
another poem
thank you your boy logie bear
was very poetic
okay not holding back
i wouldn't mind the trade on e4
wow
[Music]
thank you s terry
also thanks s terry for sending me
cookies at one time cookies were
delicious
i'm pretty sure
that's the same person
okay what to do and i hear here
i think i'll
i'll go for this queen g2 bishop e4
takes takes and
um
[Music]
i'll remove the knight and then get an
outpost on f3
yeah starting
with this
it's going to be really hard for white
not to get forked
probably possible
[Music]
but i'm threatening to take and do this
hey it's ezra eve
not quite nine hours but almost
i didn't see that move but i guess i'll
on passant
double twitch
hey double twitch baby 18 months
is that twins or now you're just twice
the size
okay if i take
i could move here too
it's still a fight i mean black's
probably slightly better here
got some nice coordination this pawns
attacked
i might end up putting the queen on d5
like if a4 queen d5 looks nice
oh some home battle going on in chat
okay
love to read some poems but let's try
and focus
i should probably take that
like takes and then takes i think
but it takes takes if rook d7 i take on
b3
defend stuff and keep the bishop
attacked
um
yeah this should be
relatively straightforward conversion
now have two pawns
still have to watch out for my king
and this might be coming
or that
okay i'll play rook f8
so the dream would be to get the rook to
a2
and then just mate
the nightmare is getting mated
on
f7 uh
[Music]
wait what's happening after this
[Music]
move think it's okay
so the nice thing is if takes i could
just take back
because my queen defends from a distance
um i was just trying to calculate takes
uh check king f1 queen g2 king e1
i can't really deliver check without
needing to address rookie 7 with a
counter check
but i mean this should be winning
yeah it is too late to join
oh gauri's still here
if gary continues to stick around we
might do some
kung fu chess
i am holding up
it's uh it's kind of going as expected
like i've imagined
imagine i would be tired around this
point
um
i haven't made too many
serious plunders
made a few though
check
okay so the king's tied down to the rook
king f1 is forced
and now
[Music]
yeah i'm just calculating a bit slower
than normally
m rose
thank you oh smith
hey the stephen gray is back
kung fu the legend katni news
still wanna do real life kung fu chess
where's my mate
i might be searching for something which
just doesn't exist yet
or maybe it does maybe i just have to
keep looking
carefully
you can see two probably coming
and now i'll play this
yeah this king looks very uh
checkmateable
i think made in one
i may have had other wins i'm not sure
analyze briefly afterwards
hey it's meat
thanks for the game novice55
uh if we look
abcs of chess
always be checkmating yeah
that's good life advice
okay there was some crazy made in ten
hey eric
great to see you
again congratulations on 500k plus
subscribers you deserve my man
wanted to ask for some help with a
stafford variation that probably is bad
but bad lines catch me out after dxc6 if
white
ah i know your question if white plays
d4
oh if d4 very simply you take back the
pawn
um
[Music]
you can't get the same attack as you
would normally in stafford but you win
back the pawn
and
it's a fine position
all right
take back on e4 then just play chess
from there and not lose yes usually run
into something like 2 after x4 forcing
qd7 to not lose the knight etc etc just
checking i wasn't missing some attack
variant from d
yeah against d4
will you ever go to posting three plus
our videos on youtube
enjoying the content hype rattle
oh thanks for the question
congrats on 500k subs and happy belated
birthday oh thanks so much
oh my birthday was exactly one month ago
right and not to get over here a kind of
scorpion
oh yeah there's different types of
scorpions
i feel like the texas scorpions are
they probably speak in like a southern
accent
okay uh
play bishop c4
in my caro khan video i recommend two
nights attack
but i should also make a video about two
nights attacking against a french
i think would be similar but also a bit
different in various ways
uh yeah d3
so this structure is something that
i very much enjoy
it's like they could be my cousins but
with stinger tails
oh yeah i
have to be careful about the stinger
tails
i wonder if scorpions do they evolve
into stingrays
or did stingrays evolve into scorpions
i want to play this move
black would want to take but after takes
takes i take
and then takes and life is good
okay now i want to play this move
although it's probably not good because
my knight gets trapped after
takes takes
i could go for takes an f4 looks nice
uh but then i get forked
probably not the best idea actually
okay i'll play knight here first and
then f4
this f4 first takes and then there's
some g5 eventually
oh i guess i provoked some deep
discussion
fish life came before land life
[Music]
so did the crab
come before the hedgehog
probably before the hippo too
[Music]
okay uh let's try and stay focused
it's been a long stream
yeah for those just joining i'm it's the
last round of this viewer tournament
it's a
500k celebration swiss
i appreciate everyone tuning in and for
the kind comments
the good vibes
and the interesting discussion
i'm liking this position
[Music]
crouching crab hidden
hippo and stinging stingray
yeah we should create animal names that
do actions
that have the first few letters of
whatever type of animal
it is
okay
again it's hard to say focus i'm trying
though i'm really trying
i'll play c3
just trying to open up the queen side
bumbling bumblebee
a scoring scorpion
yeah so the plan is queen b3
probably rook c1 eventually takes
trying to attack from multiple
directions
e5 is a
constant target
oh dead dinosaur
dancing dinosaur is more fun though
threatening this
probably threatening some like queen f7
okay going in
did i not accomplish that much
it really feels like there should be
some knockout blow here
um maybe b4
okay yeah the way to open the position
is with pawn brakes
so
these are two pawn breaks a lot upon
tension now
uh positions opening up e5 is now
attacked three times
yeah we're past the nine hour mark
so less than three hours to go let's go
i should eat something or i should make
more tea
i need to fill up more water
or water in the kettle though
i make more tea
i take a pawn and then oh no my queen
let's do it oh no my queen
it's really fancy actually because after
takes takes k moves takes i
would then be attacking the night in the
end
oh thank you young chess i appreciate
the comments
those are the types of comments i like
rather than you look tired
or i need to go to the store and get
some food stuffs
i just woke up i approve of this food
gathering mission
we should both go on a food gathering
mission
[Music]
we can be the gatherers
as opposed to the hunters
but i might not need food given that i'm
eating so much in this position
everything's so tasty
and take this i can take this let's take
this
okay so i'm up a rook
go after the pawn
thank you hawkeye
think you blunderlust
again really appreciate the good vibes
sorry if i'm a little bit
lower energy than normal
trying to make up for it with my play
i have this move now let's play this
move
and then
simplify even further
oh no my pawn
[Music]
i've been revising some of my jokes what
did elmer fudd say to chewbacca after he
blundered it's okay chewie we all make
wookie mistakes elma makes more sense
than luke
okay you've won the joke contest earlier
we were having a joke contest
whoever tells the best joke
it's gifted a sub
but
okay
thanks for the game
pick a dag
did i
manage i think i managed good job to
jewel still playing though
oh jewels might lose on time
also thanks to everyone for playing 318
people
at least hopefully mostly people
good variety
st louis chess club still streaming yeah
harrison kaiser
uh is playing arcg3
oh thank you jaybird congrats on the
500k and tourney
thank you it's not over yet
i think i'm safely in first
watch the final game though
another game where like all three
results are possible
oh ever have i heard of the chess
premier league
i saw something about it but i'm not so
well informed what do you call a
five-foot tall psychic who's escaped
from jail a small medium at large
small media ah that's so good
i haven't heard that one before
wait i already said i won't do a 24 hour
stream
i might go back on that
if i do hit a million i'll i'll see
at a million subs i'll either do a
24-hour stream or like a freestyle rap
or both
we'll see
oh this game's heating up
a 12-hour rap stream that's what harry
mack did when he hit
a million subs on youtube
he rapped her
12 maybe it was 10 i think it was 10
hours nonstop
it was pretty crazy
what do you call the elderly ants that
hang out at geico insurance
oh i saw that coming
i could do another cooking stream
the
could be appetizing
wow
[Music]
oh rook d7 was only a move there
well gg
is it winning
it seems close to winning i'm not sure
though
d7 it's a long like kingpin ending
it might not be winning actually
wait a minute
what's happening here if rook d7
oh i can just leave the tension and walk
around
and then it's winning
ah okay nice play from white
oh the tournament's over
google's in second camel in third
okay let's get some confetti
thanks everyone for participating